This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If I asked you to think of the most famous architect in American history, even if you don't think you know anything at all about architecture, I bet you could take a guess and I bet your guess would be right. Frank Lloyd Wright. Frank Lloyd Wright, perhaps the greatest architect of the 20th century. The genius with a T-square has been called the paste center of modern-day architecture. One of the most extraordinary man of art is I. He has literally established the pace for innovations and new ideas in the field of architecture. Frank Lloyd Wright left a legacy of some of the most iconic and gorgeous buildings in the United States,
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。如果我让你想出美国历史上最著名的建筑师，即使你认为自己对建筑一窍不通，我敢打赌你也能猜出来，而且我敢打赌你猜得没错。弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特。弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特，或许是20世纪最伟大的建筑师。这位拥有T形尺的天才被称为现代建筑的基石。他是最杰出的艺术大师之一。他确实为建筑领域的创新和新思想设定了步伐。弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特留下了美国一些最具标志性和华丽的建筑遗产，
like the Spiraling Guggenheim Museum in New York, the Falling Waterhouse in Pennsylvania, which straddles a waterfall, and the futuristic Marin Civic Center, which is the backdrop for Gatica, which is an awesome movie. And that is producer Avery Truffleman. By the end of his career, Wright was on a level of celebrity,
比如纽约螺旋形的古根海姆博物馆，宾夕法尼亚州横跨瀑布的流水别墅，以及作为《千钧一发》这部精彩电影背景的未来派马林县政务中心。那是制作人艾弗里·特鲁夫曼。到他职业生涯末期，赖特的知名度达到了，
usually reserved for actors and rock stars. He was a household name, and he was on late-night talk shows. Some quarters have denounced Wright as an impractical visionary and a puffer's windbag. He was a household name, and he was on late night talk shows. So Wright wasn't just known for being a genius architect. He made headlines because he was a character. He often wore this outfit that included a flowy cape and a hat and cane. He wrote manifestos, launched insults at other architects,
通常只有演员和摇滚明星才能享有的水平。他是家喻户晓的人物，经常出现在深夜脱口秀节目中。一些人曾谴责赖特是一个不切实际的空想家和吹牛大王。他是家喻户晓的人物，经常出现在深夜脱口秀节目中。所以赖特不仅因为是天才建筑师而闻名。他之所以成为头条新闻，是因为他个性鲜明。他经常穿着那种包括飘逸斗篷、帽子和手杖的服装。他撰写宣言，对其他建筑师进行人身攻击，
and loudly critiqued politicians, religion, and society. He declared himself the greatest architect who ever lived. He was unashamed. He's the early in life I had to choose between honest arrogance and hypocritical humility. I chose honest arrogance and hypocritical humility. I chose honest arrogance and have seen no occasion to change now.
并大声批评政客、宗教和社会。他宣称自己是有史以来最伟大的建筑师。他毫不羞愧。他曾说：早年我必须在诚实的傲慢和虚伪的谦逊之间做出选择。我选择了诚实的傲慢，至今没有理由改变。
And Frank Lloyd Wright had this wildly scandalous private life. There were suits against him, property seed, jail, finally divorce. The raw material for big, spicy headlines, Frank Lloyd Wright was the darling of a sensational press. But this bombastic character ultimately changed the field of architecture and introduced a new philosophy of building. Before many of Wright's iconic and famous structures were completed, before falling water, before
弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特有着极其丑闻不断的私生活。针对他的诉讼、财产查封、入狱，最终离婚。这些是重大、劲爆头条新闻的原材料，弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特是轰动性媒体的宠儿。但这位夸夸其谈的人物最终改变了建筑领域，并引入了一种新的建筑哲学。在赖特许多标志性和著名的建筑完工之前，在流水别墅之前，在
the Guggenheim, before the Marin Civic Center, his most significant contribution to our everyday lives was something much more modest. A small, sturdy, inexpensive, and most importantly, very beautiful house designed with the American working class in mind, and it all started with a journalist from Milwaukee. In 1934, a Milwaukee journal reporter named Herbert Jacobs was assigned to take a drive over to Spring Green in Central Wisconsin. He was told to write about Tally Esson, Frank Lloyd Wright's home and studio. Jacobs didn't really know anything about architecture, and at that particular time,
古根海姆博物馆之前，在马林县政务中心之前，他对我们日常生活最重要的贡献要谦逊得多。那是一座小巧、坚固、廉价，最重要的是非常美丽的房子，它是为美国工人阶级设计的，而这一切都始于密尔沃基的一位记者。1934年，密尔沃基日报的一名记者赫伯特·雅各布斯被指派开车前往威斯康星州中部的斯普林格林。他被要求写一篇关于塔里埃森的文章，那是弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特的家和工作室。雅各布斯对建筑一无所知，而且在那个时候，
he wasn't really interested in learning anything about it. Because Herbert Jacobs had other things on his mind. In that November of 1934, his wife was very, very pregnant. The night before his reporting trip, he had brought her to the hospital and stayed up with her until dawn. The nurse has assured her birth that he could go on his reporting trip without missing the birth. And so, he set out that morning alone. Blirriade, completely unprepared.
他其实并不想学习任何相关知识。因为赫伯特·雅各布斯当时有别的心事。1934年11月，他的妻子怀孕了，而且临产在即。在他报道行程的前一天晚上，他把她送到了医院，并一直陪着她直到天亮。护士向她保证，他可以去进行报道行程，而不会错过孩子的出生。于是，那天早上他独自出发了。完全没有准备。
He drove 120 miles through the chill, gray Wisconsin countryside for his assignment. To me, with Frank Lloyd Wright. Wright, who was 67 in 1934, couldn't have cared less about his appointment with Herbert Jacobs of the Milwaukee Journal. Actually, Wright forgot all about it, which wasn't unusual. He was known to blow off journalists. When Jacob arrived at Frank Lloyd Wright's compound, completely distracted by thoughts of his wife and their baby, he learned that the architect was actually on his way out the door. They got to talk
他开车穿过寒冷、灰暗的威斯康星乡村，行驶了120英里去完成他的任务。去见弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特。1934年时年67岁的赖特，根本不在乎他与密尔沃基日报赫伯特·雅各布斯的预约。事实上，赖特完全忘了这件事，这并不罕见。他以放记者鸽子而闻名。当雅各布斯到达弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特的庄园时，他满脑子都是妻子和孩子，心不在焉，他得知这位建筑师实际上正准备出门。他们谈了
for just over 10 minutes before Wright left abruptly saying, some of the boys will talk to you now. The boys were Frank Lloyd Wright's apprentices. They had come to him from all over the world, and they're a part of a fellowship program that Wright established at his home in studio, a campus he called Tally Essin. Tally Essin, a Welsh word, meaning shining brow. Welsh because it was built on land settled by his family who were farmers from Wales, but the shining brow also has to do with Wright's building philosophy. So Taliesin actually is built kind of on the brow, just like your brow of your head. The main Taliesin building crumbles
不到10分钟，赖特就突然离开，说：“小伙子们会跟你谈的。”这些小伙子是弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特的学徒。他们从世界各地来到他身边，是赖特在他家和工作室建立的奖学金项目的一部分，他称这个园区为塔里埃森。塔里埃森，一个威尔士语单词，意为“闪亮的额头”。之所以用威尔士语，是因为它建在他家族定居的土地上，他的家人是来自威尔士的农民，但“闪亮的额头”也与赖特的建筑哲学有关。塔里埃森实际上是建在额头上的，就像你头部的额头一样。塔里埃森的主建筑环绕着
around the side of a hill, almost like a crown. He felt that you should never build on top of a hill because that destroyed the integrity of the hill. This is Floyd Hamlin. He's an architect at Taliesin. Also part of the integrity of the hill. This is Floyd Hamlin. He's an architect at Tally Essin. Also, part of the faculty of the Frank Lloyd Wright School of Architecture, and I've been here since starting as a apprentice back in 1987. Hamlin works and lives at Tally Essin full-time. Here on Frank Lloyd Wright's family land, we're right used to play as a boy. So, yeah, where are we now?
山坡，几乎像一个皇冠。他认为你不应该在山顶上建造，因为那会破坏山的完整性。这是弗洛伊德·哈姆林。他是塔里埃森的一名建筑师。也是山体完整性的一部分。这是弗洛伊德·哈姆林。他是塔里埃森的一名建筑师。也是弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特建筑学院的教员，我从1987年开始作为学徒来到这里。哈姆林全职在塔里埃森工作和生活。就在弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特儿时玩耍的家族土地上。所以，是的，我们现在在哪里？
So where are we? We are. This is just outside of Spring Green, Wisconsin. It's a very beautiful green valley with rolling hills. So he spent a lot of his summers working this land. So he was very familiar with the landscape. And this connection with the outdoors was really formative for right.
我们现在在哪里？我们就在威斯康星州斯普林格林郊外。这是一个非常美丽的绿色山谷，有起伏的丘陵。他夏天经常在这片土地上工作。所以他对这里的景观非常熟悉。这种与户外的联系对赖特来说确实具有塑造意义。
He thought that architecture should help people live harmoniously with their environment, rather than shield them from it. The house could become part of nature if it was made with local materials and had big windows and was oriented for just the right amount of sunlight. You orient the house just right so that you take advantage of what nature has to offer
他认为建筑应该帮助人们与环境和谐相处，而不是将他们与环境隔绝。如果房子是用当地材料建造的，有大窗户，并且朝向能获得恰到好处的阳光，那么房子就可以成为自然的一部分。你把房子的朝向调整得恰到好处，这样你就能利用大自然所提供的一切，
and you're living with nature rather than trying to fight against it. You know, living on the brow of the hill, not on top of it. This all folded into a concept, Frank Lloyd Wright called Organic Architecture. He wanted to spread this gospel to the next generation, which is why he returned to the valley he knew as a boy and established the Talias and Fellowship. The Fellowship was the thing that the Milwaukee Journal wanted Herbert Jacobs to cover in his article. When Jacobs drove into Talias and that morning in 1934, the Fellowship had been going on for two years, and it was hard for the public to wrap their minds around it, including this NBC announcer. The apprentices had to pay $1,100 a year to attend the Taliesin Fellowship, nearly 20 grand today,
你是在与自然共存，而不是试图对抗它。你知道，住在山坡上，而不是山顶上。这一切都融入了一个概念，弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特称之为“有机建筑”。他想把这个福音传播给下一代，这就是为什么他回到他儿时熟悉的山谷，并建立了塔里埃森奖学金项目。这个奖学金项目就是密尔沃基日报希望赫伯特·雅各布斯在文章中报道的内容。当雅各布斯在1934年那个早晨开车进入塔里埃森时，这个项目已经进行了两年，公众很难理解它，包括这位NBC播音员。学徒们每年必须支付1100美元才能参加塔里埃森奖学金项目，相当于今天的近2万美元，
and it wasn't like an accredited institution or anything. Students had to do a lot of grunt work like bailing hay, plowing fields, and making meals. But they got to learn Frank Lloyd Wright's philosophy of architecture and live with them and work with them. Even though oftentimes this meant serving as an unpaid labor force. When Jacobs was getting his tour of Tally Essin, he described the apprentices as rather long-haired, smiling, and polite young men, who tried their best to explain to him
而且它也不是什么认证机构。学生们必须做很多苦力活，比如打捆干草、耕地和做饭。但他们可以学习弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特的建筑哲学，并与他一起生活和工作。尽管这往往意味着充当无薪劳动力。当雅各布斯参观塔里埃森时，他形容学徒们是“留着长发、面带微笑、彬彬有礼的年轻人”，他们尽最大努力向他解释
what organic architecture means. Organic architecture is architecture of its time and of its place. You're not trying to make it look like something that it's not. Right thought that there should be no wallpaper to cover things up. No paint, no plaster. Wood should look like wood, stone should look like stone. Concrete should look like concrete. When Frank Lloyd Wright worked with plywood, he liked to leave the edge of the plywood exposed so that
有机建筑意味着什么。有机建筑是属于其时代和地点的建筑。你不是试图让它看起来像它本来不是的东西。赖特认为不应该用壁纸来遮盖东西。没有油漆，没有灰泥。木头应该看起来像木头，石头应该看起来像石头。混凝土应该看起来像混凝土。当弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特使用胶合板时，他喜欢让胶合板的边缘露出来，这样
you saw those layers in there and that became part of the almost ornament or detail. Which was different from frilly traditional European style architecture with rococo gold ornaments and clothet chairs and parlors full of knick-knacks. Just think of Victorian houses stuffed with lots of tiny rooms and covered in bright paint and lacy curtains. This idea of organic architecture wasn't just a break from these traditions. It was a break from new trends in modern architecture too. Cities all over the world were building huge, boxy, glass and steel structures, designed to be hypersleek machines for living and working. Wright explains that these were simply not comfortable for human animals.
你就能看到里面的层理，这几乎成了装饰或细节的一部分。这与带有洛可可式金色装饰、布艺椅子和摆满小摆设的客厅的华丽传统欧洲风格建筑不同。试想一下维多利亚时代的房子，塞满了许多小房间，覆盖着明亮的油漆和蕾丝窗帘。这种有机建筑的理念不仅是对这些传统的突破。它也是对现代建筑新趋势的突破。世界各地的城市都在建造巨大的、方方正正的玻璃和钢结构建筑，旨在成为超时尚的生活和工作机器。赖特解释说，这些对人类动物来说根本不舒服。
They are like goldfish and a globe. And these houses that are so classified as they know are, they're not sensible, it's an abuse of privilege and an abuse of material. Frank Lloyd Wright took the traditional old materials and put them into sleek modern forms. His organic architecture was a new style, born in the United States. And organic architecture, a new sense of what constitutes humanity under harmonious conditions, a harmonious place in which to live and harmonious way to live in it. But Frank Lloyd Wright didn't explain this grand philosophy
它们就像金鱼缸里的金鱼。这些被归类为房子的建筑，它们不合理，这是对特权的滥用，也是对材料的滥用。弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特采用了传统的旧材料，并将它们放入时尚的现代形式中。他的有机建筑是一种在美国诞生的新风格。有机建筑，一种在和谐条件下构成人类的新感觉，一个和谐的居住场所和一种和谐的生活方式。但弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特并没有向记者赫伯特·雅各布斯解释这种宏大的哲学，
to the journalist Herbert Jacobs, because Wright wasn't there. The apprentices did the best they could, but again, Jacobs was very distracted and was only thinking of his wife in the hospital. He thanked the two young men who showed him around Tallyess and got back in his car. Jacobs later wrote, finally I started back to Milwaukee, learning on the way through a telephone call young man who showed him around Tallyesson and got back in his car. Jacob's later road.
因为赖特当时不在那里。学徒们尽了最大努力，但雅各布斯依然非常心不在焉，只想着医院里的妻子。他感谢了带他参观塔里埃森的那两个年轻人，回到了车里。雅各布斯后来写道，最后我开始返回密尔沃基，在路上通过电话得知……带他参观塔里埃森的那两个年轻人，回到了车里。雅各布斯后来写道。
Funnily, I started back to Milwaukee, learning on the way through a telephone call to the hospital that I had become a father at about 11 o'clock that morning, at the very moment when I was interviewing right. Herbert Jacob's, his wife, Catherine, and their new daughter, lived in Milwaukee for two more years on his reporter's salary of $20 a week. This was in the mid-30s, the Great Depression. So when Herbert Jacobs was offered a slightly higher-paying job with a paper in the state capital of medicine, the family moved right away.
有趣的是，我开始返回密尔沃基，在路上通过给医院打的电话得知，那天上午11点左右，就在我采访赖特的时候，我当爸爸了。赫伯特·雅各布斯、他的妻子凯瑟琳和他们的新生女儿在密尔沃基又住了两年，靠他每周20美元的记者薪水生活。那是30年代中期，大萧条时期。所以当赫伯特·雅各布斯在州首府麦迪逊的一家报社获得一份薪水稍高的工作时，全家立刻搬走了。
When we got to Madison, I couldn't find anything within our price range and our newspaper man's price range. It was what we figured would be nice to live in. This is the voice of Herbert Jacobs himself from a 1956 NBC interview. When he and Catherine moved to Madison, they didn't see any houses they liked, or that they could afford. So a cousin of my wife had been out at Taliesin and Mr. Wright and suggested that we have Mr. Wright do something for us. Jacobs didn't really remember much about his first visit to Taliassin two years before. And he murmured something along the lines of,
当我们到达麦迪逊时，我在我们的价格范围内找不到任何东西，在报社记者的价格范围内。这就是我们认为住起来会不错的地方。这是赫伯特·雅各布斯本人在1956年NBC采访中的声音。当他和凯瑟琳搬到麦迪逊时，他们没有看到任何他们喜欢或买得起的房子。所以，我妻子的一个表亲去过塔里埃森，见过赖特先生，并建议我们让赖特先生为我们做点什么。雅各布斯对两年前第一次访问塔里埃森的记忆并不多。他嘟囔了一些类似的话，
very interesting, which his wife's cousin took as a yes. But he made an appointment for us to go out there and we went along with that idea. And then on the way out, we were, my wife and I, were trying to think, what is it that we can tell this great man, the architect of rich plants, what can we say to him that would interest him in our very small case? In the past, when Frank Lloyd Wright had designed private homes, they had not been for people like Herbert and Catherine Jacobs. Wright had designed gorgeous, wide homes with broad roofs and expensive living rooms
“非常有意思”，他的妻子的表亲把它当作了“同意”。但他为我们预约了去那里，我们就照做了。在去的路上，我和妻子都在想，我们能对这位伟人、富人豪宅的建筑师说些什么呢？我们能对他说些什么来引起他对我们这个非常小的案例的兴趣呢？过去，当弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特设计私人住宅时，它们并不是为像赫伯特和凯瑟琳·雅各布斯这样的人设计的。赖特设计过华丽、宽敞的住宅，有着宽阔的屋顶和昂贵的客厅，
for wealthy people. His constructions were masterpieces. They were works of art and they were expensive. So we put it as a sort of challenge. But the country needs is a decent $5,000 house. Can you build one? In today's money, $5,000 is about $85,000. That's a pretty reasonably priced house in most real estate markets. Mr. Wright told us that we were the first clients that ever asked him to build a low-cost house. He said, for 20 years, you've been wanting to build one, but no one ever asked him to. Now Wright had long wanted to make a more democratic form of housing, even early in his career. He had been playing around with inexpensive methods of building and other structures, and he had a lot of concepts that he had been scheming around urban planning.
是为富人设计的。他的建筑是杰作。它们是艺术品，而且很昂贵。所以我们把它当作一种挑战。“国家需要的是体面的5000美元的房子。你能盖一栋吗？”按今天的货币计算，5000美元大约是85000美元。在大多数房地产市场，这都是一栋价格相当合理的房子。赖特先生告诉我们，我们是第一批要求他建造低成本住宅的客户。他说，20年来，他一直想盖一栋，但从来没有人要求他盖。现在，赖特有机会将他的一些概念变为现实。他有了愿意配合的客户，而且他有时间。1936年，他的职业生涯处于低谷。人们买不起昂贵的新豪宅。同样，那是大萧条时期，许多大型项目被取消了，而且赖特已经从业几十年了，他正慢慢被视为过气人物。然后这对年轻、思想开放的夫妇来了，赖特可以告诉他们他的哲学，并
But now, Wright had the chance to make some of his concepts a reality. He had the willing clients, and he had time on his hands. In 1936, he was in a bit of a slump in his career. People couldn't afford fancy big new homes. Again, it was the depression, and a number of big projects had been canceled, and also Wright had already been practicing for decades, and he was slowly getting written off as a husband. And then incomes this young, open-minded couple, Wright could tell them his philosophy, and
通过好的建筑教他们如何过上好生活。然后他说：“你们真的想要一栋5000美元的房子吗？他说大多数人想用5000美元买一栋10000美元的房子。你们愿意放弃必须放弃的东西吗？”赖特先生列出了一份清单，如果他们真的想要一栋5000美元的房子，雅各布斯夫妇就必须放弃这些东西。瓷砖浴室、额外的装饰、饰面等等。“你们愿意放弃这些吗？”
teach them how to live well through good architecture. Then he said, do you really want a $5,000 house? He said most people want a $10,000 house for $5,000. Are you willing to give up the things that you have to give up? Mr. Wright made a list of the things that the Jacobs would have to do without if they really wanted a $5,000 house. Tile bathrooms, extra trim, finish, and things like that. Are you willing to give those up?
我们对此一无所知，我们说：“当然，我们没问题。”赫伯特和凯瑟琳·雅各布斯当时并不知道，弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特为他们建造的那座朴素的小房子将是他意识形态最实际的体现。雅各布斯一家将拥有赖特称之为“尤索尼亚”运动中的第一栋房子。赫伯特·雅各布斯建造的房子是第一栋尤索尼亚住宅。尤索尼亚，一个赖特创造的词，意为“美国应该是它民主巅峰的样子”。
We didn't know anything about it and we said, sure, it's okay with us. Herbert and Catherine Jacobs didn't know it at the time, but that modest little house that Frank Lloyd Wright was to build for them would be the most practical expression of his ideology. The Jacobs would own the first house in a movement that right-called euconia. The house that Herbert Jacobs built was the first of the euconian houses. Euconian, a right-word meaning the United States is it ought to be at its democratic zenith.
尤索尼亚是弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特对北美合众国的称呼。在赖特的愿景中，尤索尼亚将是一个充满朴素、制作精良、美丽、舒适的小房子的国家，工人阶级买得起。这些尤索尼亚住宅将激励、教育，赖特相信，为所有美国人创造一种新文化。我相信现在人们会知道什么是好的建筑，当然好的生活也随之而来。良好的行为也是。
Euconia was Frank Lloyd Wright's name for the United States of North America. In Wright's vision, euconia would be a country full of modest, well-made, beautiful, comfortable little houses that the working class could afford. These Eusonian homes would inspire, educate, and write believed create a new culture for all Americans. I believe now people are going to know what constitutes good architecture and of course good living has to go with it. Good conduct also.
良好的着装也是，因为你不会在一个安静而美丽的房间里以吵闹和粗俗的方式着装。所有这些美好的事物或多或少地相互依赖，并加起来构成我们称之为文化的东西。只有通过自然生长，你才能获得文化。赖特认为建立更好的美国文化的方法不是大规模的，不是公寓楼或千篇一律的开发项目。
Good dressing too because you wouldn't dress in a loud and vulgar way in a quiet and beautiful room. All these good things are dependent more or less one on the other and add up to something that we call culture. It's only by a natural growth that you can attain culture. Right believe the way to build a better American culture was not en masse, not in apartment buildings or cookie cutter developments.
而是要迎合个人。文化不是为了俱乐部。文化是个人的事情。这就是我们的先辈在宣布个人是主权者时所强调的。这对于弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特来说，意味着大众应该“去大众化”。他们应该分散开来，远离城市。嗯，城市当然是过去的事物了。在中世纪，曾有一段时间，那是文化的唯一来源。
It was to be catered to the individual. Culture is not for the club. Culture is an individual thing. And that's what our forefathers struck when they declared that the individual is sovereign. Which, to Frank Lloyd Wright, meant that the masses should be unmasked. They should spread out, away from the city. Well, the city, of course, is a thing of the past. There was a time during the Middle Ages when there was the only source of culture.
除了直接接触，没有其他方式可以获得我们称之为文化的东西，你明白吗。但对赖特来说，那不再是事实了。人们通过收音机、电话和汽车与文化相连。他们有交通、速度、倾听，这是我们现在正在使用的。人们不再有必要挤在任何地方。这些都是弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特对美国愿景的一部分。这一切将在1936年随着雅各布斯住宅开始成为现实，
There was no way of acquiring this thing we call culture, except by direct contact, you see. But for right, that wasn't true anymore. People were connected to culture through radio and telephones and automobiles. They have transportation, speed, listening, this, or we're using now. It's no longer essential for people to crowd together anywhere. These were all parts of Frank Lloyd Wright's vision for America. And this would start to become reality in 1936 with the Jacob's house,
它后来被称为“雅各布斯一号”或“尤索尼亚一号”。雅各布斯住宅是建造的第一批住宅之一。建造时这里只是一片广阔的农田。这是比尔·马蒂内利，尤索尼亚一号的经理。它位于麦迪逊郊外的一条郊区街道上，现在街道两旁都是小型的郊区住宅，但尤索尼亚一号确实很突出。
which would come to be known as Jacob's one, or Eusoneo one. Jacob's house was one of the first ones built. This was just a wide open farmland when it was built out here. This is Bill Martinelli, manager of Eusoneo 1. It's in a suburban street outside of Madison, now lined with little suburban houses, but Eusoneo 1 really stands out.
即使你不知道它是什么，只是开车经过，因为它从街上看，几乎就像一面美丽的木墙。房子背对着马路。嗯，当我们进入里面或者绕到后面时，你会看到房子的整个背面都是玻璃。它完全向后方开放。你知道，我们是故意这样做的，它在街道一侧封闭，然后在背面打开。
Even if you don't know what it is and you're just driving by, because from the street, it almost just looks like a beautiful wooden wall. The house turns its back on the road. Well, when we get inside or if we go around back, you'll see the whole back of the house is all glass. It's all open to the back. And you know, we did that intentionally, and it kind of closed it off to the street and then opened it up to the back.
正如赖特所见，房子的重点不是要有一个巨大的门面来向邻居炫耀，前面有一个无用且浪费的草坪和宏伟的入口。不。房子应该为居民而建，而不是为旁观者。此外，从街上你可以看到没有车库。汽车停在木制遮阳棚下，只是一个没有侧墙的小平屋顶。这就是“车棚”，
As Wright saw it, the point of the house was not to have a big facade to show off to your neighbors with a useless and wasteful patch of lawn in the front in a grand entryway. No. The house should be built for residents, not onlookers. Also, from the street, you can see that there's no garage. A car is parked under a wooden awning, just a little flat roof with no sidewalls. This is the carport,
一个弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特创造的术语。这是赖特降低成本的许多微小方式之一，而且车棚也是一种生活方式的教育。没有车库，雅各布斯一家就没有空间存放他们的垃圾。他们必须简单地减少他们的财产，扔掉他们不需要的东西。但车棚并非纯粹实用。车棚屋顶上的木制品有一种可爱的几何图案。就像天花板上的木条纹一样。
a term that Frank Lloyd Wright coined. This was one of the many tiny ways Wright kept costs down, and also the carport was an education in lifestyle. Without a garage, the Jacobs wouldn't have space to store their junk. They'd have to simply minimize their possessions and toss what they didn't need. But the carport isn't purely utilitarian. The woodwork on the carport roof has this lovely geometric pattern. It was like these wood kind of stripes in the ceiling.
是的，很有趣，当我听说车棚并看到它的照片时，我没想到它会这么漂亮，而且它真的很不错。这是这栋房子里的东西，你看得越多，看到的就越多，你知道，就像车棚里的天花板，你不会想到那个。当你进入里面时，你会看到同样的东西。尤索尼亚一号充满了小巧、优雅的细节。我们可以进去吗？当然。
Yeah, it's funny when I heard about the carport and like scene pictures of it, I didn't expect it to be so beautiful and like, it's really nice. It's the thing in this house, the more you look around the around, the more you see, you know, like with the ceiling here in the carport, you wouldn't expect that. When you get inside, you'll see the same thing. You Sonya 1 is full of small, elegant details. Can we go inside? Sure.
当然。里面很暖和。哦，哇。你可以看到阳光是如何照进来的。它是如此红，就像砖块和木头和……对。你的眼睛会被吸引进去。尤索尼亚一号是一层楼，里面基本上是一个房间和一只吵闹的猫。空间完全开放，客厅、餐厅、厨房之间没有墙。这在当时是相当
Sure. A warm in here. Oh, wow. You can see how the sun comes in. It's so red, like the brick and the wood and the... Right. Your eye kind of gets drawn in. You Sonya 1 is one floor, and inside it's pretty much one room and a loud cat. The space is all open, no walls between living room, dining room, kitchen. That was kind
创新的。厨房是一个毗邻客厅/餐厅空间的壁龛，没有门。这是一个非常、非常小的区域。这就是厨房。我想它只比我双臂展开的长度宽一点点。但每一平方英尺，可能吧。有一个带小卧室的小走廊，但主要是那个主房间是焦点。那是你应该吃饭、放松、阅读、生活，都在一起的地方。
of innovative for the time. The kitchen is an alcove adjacent to the living slash dining space, with no door. It's a very, very tiny area. This is the kitchen. It's just a little bit wider than the length of my arms, I think. But each foot quite, each foot square, probably. There's a small hallway with tiny bedrooms, but mostly the one main room is the focus. It's where you're supposed to eat, relax, read, live, all together.
再次是赫伯特·雅各布斯。赖特先生是开放式平面图和住房的倡导者，即移除盒子里的盒子，这样你就不会有太多的隔断。诱惑是更多地在一起。开放式平面图相当新颖，而且没有太多的墙壁可以节省成本。尤索尼亚住宅充满了这些巧妙、低成本的解决方案，比如天花板上的灯。那只是一个钢槽，电线就放在里面，然后是裸露的插座、裸露的灯泡。所以这被认为是第一种轨道照明，房子的另一个第一。
Again, Herbert Jacobs. Mr. Wright is an advocate of the open plan and housing that is the removal of the boxes within boxes, sort of thing, so that you don't have many partitions. The temptation is to be together much more. The open plan was pretty novel and it was cost-saving to not have many walls. The Euconian house is full of these clever, less expensive solutions like the lights on the ceiling. So that's just a steel channel with the wires just laying in there and then bare sockets, bare bulbs. So that's considered the first track lighting, another first to the house.
现在你到处都能看到轨道照明，无论你在哪里看到固定在单根横梁上的灯或灯泡。那是尤索尼亚的发明。尤索尼亚普及的其他创新包括使用平屋顶、内置家具和加热地板。赫伯特·雅各布斯喜欢那些加热地板。地板采暖，现在很普遍，但在当时，这个国家没有地板采暖的住宅。所有这些创新都是为了帮助
And now you see track lighting everywhere, wherever you see lights or bulbs affixed to a single beam. That's a euconian invention. Other innovations euconia popularized include the use of flat roofs, built-in furniture, and heated floors. Herbert Jacobs loved those heated floors. Floor heating, now very general, but at that time there were no floor he did residences in this country. All of these innovations were meant to help the
家庭生活得既好又节俭。他们住在房子里时省了钱，而且他们在房子的建造上也节省了成本。但赖特使用了一些其他节省成本的措施，有点像作弊。比如他从他附近正在建造的另一栋建筑里偷了一些砖块。嗯，赖特并没有亲自去偷砖块。他派了一群学徒去威斯康星州的拉辛，那里他设计的庄臣蜡业大楼正在施工。他告诉学徒们尽可能多地拿砖块，并把它们带回麦迪逊。
family live well and frugally. They saved money while they lived in the house and they had also saved costs and the construction of the house. But right used some other cost-saving measures that were kind of cheating. Like he stole some bricks from another building of his that he was constructing nearby. Well, Wright didn't steal the bricks himself. He sent a bunch of his apprentices over to Racine, Wisconsin, where his design for the Johnson Wax Building was under construction. He told the apprentices to grab as many bricks as they could and bring them back to Madison.
如果你熟悉庄臣蜡业大楼，角落是弯曲的，所以你可以看到其中一些砖块是凸面的，一些是凹面的。嗯，那些就像角落砖。赖特降低成本的另一种方式是他自己大幅减薪。比尔·伊派德是5500美元，其中包括赖特先生450美元的费用。不管用什么手段，赖特做到了。他完成了建造一栋赫伯特和凯瑟琳买得起的漂亮房子的挑战。我的意思是，它并不完美。这对家庭来说是一个完全的调整。而且房子有排水问题，
If you're familiar with the Johnson Wax building the corners are curved so you can see some of these bricks are convex and some are concave. Well those would depend like corner bricks. Another way Wright kept costs down was by taking a huge pay cut himself. Bill Ipaid was for $5,500, which included Mr. Wright's fee of $450. By hook or by crook, Wright did it. He met his challenge of building a beautiful house that Herbert and Catherine could afford. I mean, it wasn't perfect. It was a total adjustment for the family. And the house had problems with rain drainage,
而且缺少一些小东西，比如最初赖特忘了在窗户上装纱窗。这正是赖特经常得到的抱怨。他主要关注美学和建筑原则，而不是实用性。最终，雅各布斯住宅太小了。在赫伯特和凯瑟琳又生了两个孩子后，他们再也住不下这栋房子了。因此，在尤索尼亚一号住了六年之后，雅各布斯一家搬到了乡下，弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特在那里为他们设计了第二栋尤索尼亚住宅。但赫伯特·雅各布斯对他们的第一个家怀有深厚的感情。住在那个房子里真是太美妙了。我想如果更多的家庭能有同样的经历会很好。
and little things were missing, like initially right for God to put screens in the windows. Which were the kinds of complaints right God a lot. He mostly focused on aesthetics and principles of building, rather than practicalities. And ultimately, the Jacob's house was small. After Herbert and Catherine had two more children, they couldn't fit into the house anymore. And so after six years of living in Eusonia one, the Jacobs family would move off to the countryside, where Frank Lloyd Wright would design them a second Eusonian house. But Herbert Jacobs thought of their first home very fondly. Living in that house was fantastically wonderful. I think it'd be nice if a lot more families had that same sort of thing happen to them.
赖特先生也这么认为。他认为每个人都应该住在他设计的房子里，你知道，餐具和衣服也是他设计的，还有所有的家具。他确实设计了很多家具，而且至少有一次，他确实为一位客户的妻子设计了一件连衣裙。这一切都是为了改变文化。一次一个家。弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特想重新设计美国，并以此类推，重新设计美国人。
Mr. Wright thought so too. He thought everybody should live in a house designed by him, and you know, the dishes and clothes designed by him in all of furniture. He did design a lot of his furniture, and in at least one case, he did design a dress for the wife of a client. This was all about changing culture. One home at a time. Frank Lloyd Wright wanted to redesign America, and by that token, Americans.
他认为好的设计会使国家变得更友善、更美丽、更开明。如今，尤索尼亚住宅可能在全国各地都能看到。你不需要指南。到1939年，赖特已经在全国各地建造了尤索尼亚住宅。你不需要指南。到1939年，赖特已经在全国各地建造了尤索尼亚住宅，包括阿拉巴马州、加利福尼亚州、伊利诺伊州、密歇根州和弗吉尼亚州的住宅。但他想建造更多。他想拥有一个中央工厂，
Good design he thought would make a kinder, more beautiful, more enlightened country. Nowadays, usonian houses may be seen the country wide. You don't need a guidebook. By 1939, Wright had built usonian homes all over the country wide. You don't need a guide book. By 1939, Wright had built Euconian homes all over the country, including houses in Alabama, California, Illinois, Michigan, and Virginia. But he wanted to build more. He wanted to have a central factory
制造预制的尤索尼亚部件，可以根据每个客户对空间和场地条件的需求进行修改。最初，整个想法是所有这些墙壁都将在工厂制造，但这从未真正实现。这都是现场建造的。弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特的尤索尼亚住宅工厂从未实现。而且赖特越来越清楚，大萧条之后，尤索尼亚住宅5000美元的价格标签根本不可行。
that made prefabricated Euconian parts modifiable for each client, depending on their needs for space and site conditions. And originally, the whole idea was all these walls would be manufactured in a factory that never really happened. This was all site built. Frank Lloyd writes factory for Euconian Homes never came to pass. And it became increasingly clear to write that the $5,000 price tag for Euconian Homes just wasn't feasible after the Depression.
此外，赖特的职业生涯在尤索尼亚一号之后不久就有了起色。他开始建造更大的委托项目，也就是我们都知道他的那些，比如流水别墅。在赖特的住宅中，没有比埃德加·考夫曼在宾夕法尼亚州的家更广为人知的了，它横跨瀑布。赖特一直致力于尤索尼亚住宅的设计，直到他生命的尽头。但正是他的一群学徒通过建造整个尤索尼亚住宅社区来延续他的愿景。在尤索尼亚路右转。
Also Wright's career picked up shortly after Euconia won. He started building bigger commissions, the ones we all know him for, like falling water. Among the Wright houses none has been more widely publicized than the Pennsylvania home of Edgar Kaufman, which straddles the waterfall. Wright worked on Euconian Homes up until near the very end of his life. But it was a group of his apprentices that would carry on his vision by building an entire community of Eusonian houses. Turn right onto Eusonian Road.
下次在《99%隐形》中，我们将前往纽约尤索尼亚，看看弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特的愿景变成了什么，以及为什么这些小房子影响了我们的生活方式。《99%隐形》本周由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼制作，塞里夫西夫、布莱尼·霍尔、米西特·杰拉德、萨姆·格林斯潘和我罗曼·马斯参与。凯蒂·明格尔是我们的高级编辑。科尔·斯特德是我们的数字总监。肖恩·里亚尔为本集创作了所有原创音乐。特兰·马扎是男爵夫人。
Next time, on 99% invisible, a trip to Eusonia, New York to see what became a frankloid rights vision, and why these little houses have affected the ways we live. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Avery Troufflement with Serifusive, Blaney Hall, and Mithit's Gerald, Sam Greenspan, and me Roman Mars. Katie Mingle is our senior editor. Cole Stead is our digital director. Sean Rial composed all original music for this episode. And Terran Mazza is the Baroness.
本周特别感谢约翰和贝蒂·摩尔、约翰·艾夫勒、吉姆·夏普、萨姆·夏普、克里斯汀·英格拉姆和乔迪·麦奎尔。我们是旧金山91.7KLW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心电台街制作。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIOrg，我们在Instagram和Tumblr上也有账号。但如果你在生活中发现自己需要真正讲述得好、设计精美的故事，你应该寻找并花时间在unin-ipi.org上。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
Special thanks this week to John and Betty Moore, John Eifler, Jim Sharp, Sam Sharp, Christine Ingram and Jody McGuire. We are a project of 91.7KLW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI Org, where on Instagram and Tumblr too. But if in the course of your life you find yourself in need of really well-tolled, beautiful, design stories, you should seek out and spend time on unin-ipi.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本周特别感谢John和Betty Moore、John Eifler、Jim Sharp、Sam Sharp、Christine Ingram以及Jody McGuire。我们是旧金山91.7 KLW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心Radio Row制作。您可以在Facebook上找到我们的节目并参与讨论。您可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIOrg，我们也在Instagram和Tumblr上。如果您在生活中需要一些讲述得非常好、关于美丽设计的精彩故事，请务必访问99pi.org。本集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。